I would like to welcome our great
presenters today so Professor Bob Sutton
and professor huggy Rao so Bob and
Huggies research at Stanford is really
focused on organizational behavior and
management and they've co-authored
scaling up excellence getting to more
without settling for Less which was
published back in 2014
scaling excellence feeling of excellence
is Wall Street Journal and Publishers
Weekly bestseller and was selected as
one of the best business books of the
year by Amazon the Financial Times The
Globe and Mail and the Library Journal
so it's a pleasure to have you know Bob
and Huggy to have you both here with us
today and you know I'll hand it off to
the real stars of the show all right
thank you so very much
Mona let me echo Mona's welcome to all
of you welcome to Stanford we deeply
appreciate the fact that you're giving
us your time we realize it's our
privilege to serve you and be up
healthier to say that we live in trying
times of course is an understatement
Kovach 19 has caused wrenching
rearrangements of our life both personal
professional and social but as all of us
know crises have two dimensions on the
one hand they're a threat and on the
other they're an opportunity I'm
actually very much looking forward to a
conversation with my great friend
co-author collaborator Co wine drinker
Bob Sutton Bob's actually been studying
leadership for a very long time actually
about 30 plus years since he first
started studying organizational decline
in the Detroit area or at least in the
context of the automobile industry so
what we're going to do is we're going to
riff on a couple of questions and then
throw it open really for your questions
so that we can all have a conversation
so Bob let me take you to your wonderful
good boss bad boss and you devoted a
chapter to the idea that the best bosses
don't shirk dirty work what did you mean
by that well this is always true but
it's expressed truly terms of the co vid
madness there's all those great things
that bosses get to do like I don't know
make announcements when people win
prizes and grants and successes and good
earnings and all those wonderful things
they get to do but the path to get there
even during the best of times as well
when people have performance problems
and these days when layoffs are
unfortunately necessary for some of your
organization's takes and so on if you
look at what bad leaders do they tend to
put it off as long as possible they tend
to pass that work off to others rather
than to be responsible and accountable
but if you look at what great bosses do
a Harry Truman had it right when you
know he said you can't stand the heat
get out of the kitchen so this so inward
a time when I see what what what great
bosses are doing there they're making
the decisions that implementing it and
they're being present for their people
so and I'm not telling anything that
surprises anybody who is out there right
now that every leader I know the ones
that seem that we know so well we know
how our games are spending their days
the leaders of every corporation they're
trying to figure out how to navigate
through this really difficult mess and
that means making some tough decisions
and some of them are going to be wrong
but they better make them and they've
got to implement them that's kind of
that's kind of the first point that's
that's wonderful we may actually take
you for a moment
to Guam where the USS Roosevelt is
currently and share with our viewers
system and you know whether what
happened
there was an example of great leadership
or the lack of genuine well it certainly
was if the purpose of a great leader is
to serve as a human shield and to and to
protect the well-being the mental health
of physical health a leader certainly
captain Crozier did it but when our I
guess our now former acting secretary of
Navy is that what that huge job was mmm
ah I think that going and yelling it
scared people is just not a great idea
so that's so we're sort of - what on -
you know what one of the key messages
and I think again every leader out there
knows it knows this do we see it as
another thing is it different I think we
might have lost you briefly what should
be there is an argument even from the
fired Acting Secretary of the Navy that
he was fired in the wrong way you know
yell at people you don't insult them you
don't do it in a process that's unfair
and another example which which I just
sort of love and hate it because if you
are a leader and you need to do layoffs
or pay cuts we have a perfect example of
how not to do it just in the last couple
of weeks the CEO bird the scooter
company and if you haven't seen this
story honestly I'm not lying
what he did was apparently was his
executive assistant is that there was a
webinar on zoom' like this two minutes
long the only thing on the slide was no
human being
it was coded 19 essentially 400 people
were told you were losing their jobs now
and in those two minutes they lost their
email and their slack channel and boom
they were gone and people who missed the
two minute meeting they couldn't figure
out why they were why they I had no
ability to communicate with the company
at all so so that sort of brings me to
kind of the key message of what's going
on right now so many of you leaders out
there whether we have one employee or a
hundred thousand you're gonna have to do
some really tough things and this is
something that my friend Michael Dearing
and experienced executive said to me
years ago but there's a difference
between what you
you and how you do it so that's mostly
what we're going to talk about
throughout throughout our 45 minutes or
so together right so I love the way you
contrasted both what happened at Birth
the scooter company and the wooden spoon
of course at the USS Theodore Roosevelt
now what do you what I heard you sort of
say is in tough times you got to do the
dirty work but I'm wondering are the
principles that can actually guide the
leader in doing this work and what might
they be Heidi you're being so mature so
it sounds pretty funny just to get
leaders so he's kind of being like the
adult huggy I hardly ever get to see
this is confirmed I promise you but keep
trying how you will see how well we do
my so so so it's highly said so here's
the principles some of the key
principles and huggy had me put the dog
up because because there's this notion
that that this book good boss bad bus
where some of the stuff comes from
we almost call that book top dog on the
tightrope because it's such a balancing
act being a senior leader there's so
many different forces buffeting you so
that's where the dog comes from so just
to give you a little background as huggy
said I did my dissertation on
organizational death the process by
which organizations are closed and
should be closed including I think it
did the only organ only paper on
organizational funerals with a guy named
Stan Harris and I attended these sort of
wakes for organizations and then I did a
lot of research on organizational
decline layoffs in the like afterwards
and and as part of that I was working
with my late and great dissertation
advisor Robert elk on he just died at a
hundred years of age last year
remarkable human being and we were
looking to see so one of the hallmarks
based on what we see in organizations
and what we see in the behavioral
science literature leaders who are great
essentially making tough decisions
implementing them in Kim
creating them so these are the four
principles they're pretty obvious but
but I think if you go back to them they
help so let's start with the last one
because that's kind of the most
emotional part which is that if you as a
leader don't express human compassion in
in your behavior in acting and
compassion you are in trouble and people
will see through you and there's all
sorts of research you look at research
by gallop gallops been studying well for
30 40 years what are what are the kind
of leaders that motivate us versus
alienate us and there's more recent
research from Google and essentially if
a boss doesn't care about you as a human
being it makes you afraid and it also
makes you less willing to commit and do
good things for the organization so
that's sort of the first one so how do
you got any comments on compassion
that's something that your your grade on
it will and thank you both you know and
you were describing compassion I was
kind of wondering from a leaders point
of view on the one hand how do you sort
of balance as it were feelings of
personal vulnerability but at the same
time projecting confidence can you talk
to us a little bit about that campus
well to me there's I think there's a
difference between personal
vulnerability which was to me a sort of
insecurity I'm out of control I don't
know what's happening it and also that's
one of the classic things is when you
have leaders who lash out at people
personally and blame others and that's
that's not the kind of vulnerability you
want I think the kind of vulnerability
is this is painful for all of you all of
you this is painful for us and we
understand the effect that this is
having on your family I mean for those
of us who are home right now that's
another sort of transition i I think
that leaders who show a lot of empathy
and express the kind of pain and
difficulty and alienation while feeling
instead of just saying everything's just
fine
and then say let's stay together and do
the best that we can so so to me there's
a difference between
weakness and and sort of raw fear and
incompetence and having a realistic
assessment of the situation but let's
move forward and be the best we can
together yeah I like the way you sort of
describe it what helped me as you were
describing this bob was in moments of
crisis if employees colleagues and the
others are in the room cold fear of
course the job of the leader is to take
them to a room called home and what I as
you say very nicely was compassion is
the passageway you can't get from one
room to another without compassion I
mean yes in the feeling that they
actually care for me I think that is the
same thing so let's talk a little bit
about some of the more objective
principles in this this is something in
years of studying everything from plant
closings to layoffs to pay cuts there's
there's all sorts of academic literature
that suggests that if you're gonna have
to do this stuff and God knows just look
at the unemployment data that came out
today there's a lot of bosses out there
for having to make these wrenching
decisions there's some things you can
sort of keep in mind to at least ease
the pain both for the affected people
say that people are laid off in your
organization and those who survive the
first one is to give people as much
predictability as possible and there's
massive uncertainty out there we can't
always see people predictability but
I'll kind of give you an example is at
least you can give them some
predictability that they're gonna be
safe for a while and where this comes
from with some research done by a seldom
and a famous psychologist at Wharton and
he sort of looked to see what happened
during the Blitzkrieg during we were -
in London and it was sort of interesting
because during London what happened was
one of the reasons that it was not as
disruptive the bombing that the Germans
did constantly as it might have been to
London was they had excellent radar in
and sirens to warn people the Bombers
were coming so people who could go about
their business and when they heard the
sirens they could go when the and then
they could go into the tube and air-raid
shelters so they caught the signal
safety hypothesis and what good leaders
do and you can see this in the way that
the good versus the bad ones handle
layoffs is they try to create periods of
safety and just in our own university I
mean I think it's just the day before
yesterday we got an email from our
Provost persister L and our head of HR
and it said God knows I'm pretty sure
there's gonna be layoffs coming in
Stanford but it said to all full-time
Stanford employees um your pay and your
job is safe through June 15 and like
that's not great after June 15th but
it's better than waking up every morning
and wondering whether I'm going to be
fired today so that's kind of the first
principle oh and there's something else
that I especially at a time of fear and
uncertainty that we learned from our our
collaborator and friend John Lilly so
there are some of you out there who are
leading organizations where thank
goodness I'm not deferring the delivery
business or if you're working at zoom or
something like there's all sorts of jobs
security and you would think that when
people are are in a company where
there's no layoffs and executives will
just sort of assume this oh well they
know their jobs are safe well when all
their friends are losing their jobs in
this happen with John Lilly when you as
CEO of a company called Mozilla and it
was growing like crazy
well his employees would still be afraid
that they were gonna be laid off so to
give them some predictability and safety
he kept having to assure them over and
over again no we're actually hiring and
he said he had to say it over and over
again before they actually believed it
so that's another side of the
predictability coin that even the people
who you think have predictable safe jobs
you have to tell them over and over
again because there's so much fear out
there you know when you talk about I
love the idea of giving employees
predictability but if I can shift the
lens to the beader want leaders to
expect the unexpected
and you and I know that in studies of
crises the first queues that arrive
they're noisy you have to wait for the
other queues to come so can you talk to
us a little bit about how crises drive
up adrenaline you want to pull the
trigger you want to make a decision but
you also need a reflection you need to
go to others can you walk us through
that this is something I think you know
more about than I do huggy but but this
notion that essentially there's all
sorts of research on group dynamics and
human behavior that your first instinct
is probably wrong you know this and and
essentially at that point you know one
of the expressions we have this in our
book somewhere which we stole from Danny
Kahneman sometimes the best is advice is
don't do something just stand there
because you kind of got to figure out
what's what's going on you got assess
the situation wait for information to
unfold and in that situation and I think
the combination of predictability and
we're kind of moving into understanding
exactly what you what you say to people
is the facts aren't clear now but what
we're gonna do is we're gonna make no
decisions for a week or we're getting
the stay in the steady state and week
and then we will get back to you and and
that idea of communicating to folks that
were deal with the uncertainty but we're
trying to kind of time bracket it might
be the best thing you can do and in
general the understanding thing to go on
this is just an example is there's all
sorts of research including some great
stuff on pay cuts and plant closings
that when you that leaders who take the
time to explain why decisions have been
made the transparency and underlying
logic not too complicated because people
have a hard time processing it because
there's so much under stress that that
actually helps blunt the blow as opposed
to just looking at it just something
they just pulled out of their hat so
that's another thing there's a hallmark
of that people who implement painful
decisions do so compassion
predictability understanding and control
so so when it comes to how people do
things
people experience the process of
something like being laid off some of us
being sent home having a pay cut there's
all sorts of research that shows that
although you might not be able to
control what happens to the extent you
can give people some control over for
example whether or not they have a
little party to go and say goodbye to
people whether they can go in and clean
out their desk any sort of feeling that
they have some influence over the way
that the process unfolds and they just
aren't sort of hapless victims then
that's one of those things that reduces
the stress and there's all sorts of
research that shows that that even when
people face just an overwhelming sort of
stressor including some great research
on on women who had very serious cancer
or breast cancer I mean by a woman named
Shelly Taylor and what that research
would show is that is it some of the
women who cope with it best they find
something in their life like finishing a
project finishing a book in one case
something that they could have control
over in their life so they just didn't
feel helpless
so can we maybe get into a few of the
nuances of these principles as well bomb
user in so where would you like to begin
well let's let's start with that my
friend and just brilliant scholar Amy
Edmondson yeah is a kind of a way to
wrap up to some so Amy Edmondson is a
professor at the Harvard Business School
in his famous for her research on
psychological safety there's been well
there's been going back to her
dissertation research there's been about
30 years of research on this in fact
Google a few years back did a
large-scale study of what the hallmark
of what effective groups and teams were
and they were teams where people felt
psychologically safe they felt as if it
was safe to express concerns identify
problems and so on and and essentially
as a leader if you want to rather than
sort of sweeping the bad news under the
rug it's your responsibility if you want
effectiveness and it can essentially use
this relying this worse before better
effect
so you've got to tell the ugly truths
and you need to be safe when people tell
you the other truths and it's the quote
from Amy says if you don't get the data
about what's wrong how can you possibly
fix it one thing I would I would add
about this is that you know Amy talks
about this and she has all sorts of
research that shows that when people
don't feel psychologically safe things
go wrong and the best people also leave
organizations but as a leader you've
really got to be careful because there's
a whole bunch of research that shows
that when people deliver bad news to you
and criticize you your first reaction is
to not like them so one of the ones this
the signals I use is that if you got an
employee or a customer who tells you
something and you get mad take that as
something that you might actually try to
use and get past your anger so that to
me that's one of the first conditions in
the kind of messy situation we're in
right now if if people aren't giving you
a lot of bad news as a leader right now
that's a sign to me and you're not
giving them a lot of bad news that's
assigned to me you're living in the
culture of denial and fear ah so talk to
me about safety because when we begin we
said that crises of the one hand
constitute threat by the other they
represent opportunity opportunity to
reimagine the enterprise we imagine the
team and so forth what I heard you say
earlier about safety was psychological
safety was very essential to buffer you
from feelings of being threatened and
tunnel vision can you talk a little bit
about how safety is essential to ask
questions and really reimagine the
enterprise well we're going to talk
about innovation a little bit later but
but if people don't feel safe to try new
things to experiment hmm then that and
what we'll talk about some of the
reaction took ovid I I would almost
divide the organization's I'm looking at
it was old research by a retired friend
of ours Alan Meyer from University of
Oregon and what he shows it's actually a
study of hospital strikes in the San
Francisco Bay Area
it's essentially half the hospitals when
the strike hit they just hunkered down
and froze in and they didn't do anything
except for sort of if they viewed it as
a threat they were afraid to do anything
but in the hospitals that viewed it as
an opportunity to do things they always
wanted to do but never could do before
those were the ones that actually
enhanced their capability over a long
period of time so and certainly we are
now facing a combination of threat and
opportunity but if you only frame it as
a threat and only talk about all the
terrible things that are going to happen
and don't focus on as one of our friends
Carl Leibert and executive says playing
offense not just defense I think that
you're making a mistake for a whole
bunch of reasons
wonderful wonderful no what do people
scrutinize and pay attention to leaders
even more during crises periods of
Tranquility okay so so so our friend
Jeff Pfeffer he just wrote a piece
yesterday we're just talking about it
when we were warming up that essentially
he said that couldn't management is even
more important now than it is during
easier times and this is a classic
example there's all sorts of evidence
that that when people are actually
animals are in positions of power that
attention is directed up the hierarchy
so when you're a boss people watch you
more closely than you are watching them
and it's just because if you think about
its adaptive because you know the people
are creatures up the hierarchy they have
more power over you so I got the picture
of the baboon here because there's
evidence that when you look at a baboon
troops like our colleague Robert
Sapolsky studies baboons that that the
average member of the troop looks up at
the alpha male every 20 or 30 seconds to
see what's going on
and and I've got a little story one of
my favorite stories back at the last
meltdown 2009 I did a bunch of stuff on
being a good boss and a bad economy so
I'm talking to a group of executives
about it's kind of that prediction
understanding control stuff and this guy
walks up to me afterwards he said let me
tell you an interesting shus story and
what happened was so so
the executive vice president's wand
around the office in an executive system
walks up to him and says so when the
layoffs coming and the guy just looks
shocked and he said lay us we have an
announcement he laughs in fact they had
made a layoff decision and not told
anyone and it was very carefully
protected but the reason they figured
out that layoffs were coming was that he
had to tell sort of like poker when he
was under stress or upset he would look
at his shoes rather than look people in
the eyes and so she said to him it's an
interesting shoes day for you so we know
something's wrong and you think about
that story essentially everybody in the
office knew that he had that tell except
for him and to me that's just you know
one element of that of that when you're
in a position of authority and it's
tough times because people are afraid
they're watching your every move your
tone of voice even closer than they
usually do and that's actually rational
behavior on their part but it's applause
oh you got to be so careful about not to
accidentally say the wrong thing your
tone of voice can really have an effect
so so that's kind of the this notion of
attention in the amount that people are
scrutinizing if it gets even worse if
you're a boss during tough times
wonderful so you know if you're a boss
here of course subject to public gaze
they're constantly looking at you
absolutely tease out a couple of nuances
with respect to understanding what I'm
trying to wrap in my head is in an
organization of a couple of thousand
people they may be all different
psychological places how do I make sense
of like where they are cuz one size for
sure doesn't fit all well that's a I'm
learning this in part so my wife is CEO
of a nonprofit to call her out she's CEO
of the Girl Scouts of Northern
California so far they're holding
together pretty well but one thing that
she's kind of figured out and this is
something that you can see way back but
I'm seeing it literally happening in the
other room in my house is is that when
you're kind of in a decision-making role
so okay so you analyze the bad news you
go through and then he kind of decide
what you're going to do in her case it's
canceling some of the summer camps for
the girls but one thing that that she
sort of realized so sort of like it's as
people are in different emotional and
psychological stages and she's using the
kubler-ross analogy and if he used the
pool or Ross it's it's the reaction that
people have come to death first there's
denial then there's anger then there's
bargaining and there's acceptance well
if you're the executive and you're in
the acceptance mode about some difficult
decision but you're dealing with people
who are in denial or bargaining your
anger and and I don't know whether this
exactly applies scientifically that
model but the notion that you've kind of
got to bring people along you've got to
be patient with their emotions
you got to kind of repeat stuff over and
over again that's the kind of stuff that
you need to do and and so that one of
the that entails having some empathy for
the folks there so that so that's what I
sort of think about when it comes to
that you know and I can you uh so in
fact what she's doing she's specifically
asking people and even I think she even
did a poll on with with with some of her
employees to ask them where they were a
time cycle so yeah you can you can do
that but also sometimes that people
don't feel quite so psychologically safe
Oh sort of assuming like like they're
dumb why don't they get it can't they
soliciting fire or something not that
sort of understanding that it takes us
all a while to work through things
emotionally and of course there's
individual differences there's some
people who are going to be slower and
there's some people are going to be
faster and they and they might not be
meaning to be absent obstinate or
difficult it's just they're human beings
and we all sort of respond in different
ways right now I'm gonna take you to
perhaps another luhan's
and the new Answers has you've been you
know mentioning crises like Kobe they
create doubt ah how do you go from doubt
to confidence doubt an entirely Bentley
so so this is something of hanging
talk about constantly as isn't is that
to be a great leader essentially you're
always balancing for making the best
decisions and lemming implementing the
best decisions being certain and being
doubtful so people do want to follow
confident leaders and also decisions
that are clearly implemented are easier
to implement this oh we've got to do
this but at the same time if you have
what future is call strong opinions
strongly held if you say this is what
we're gonna do when we're absolutely
going to do it and you refuse to in your
own mind think that it might be wrong or
to invite people and say well this might
be the wrong decision
then you're not going to be able to
update so it's this combination of
starting with a fairly strong point of
view and this is back to predictability
this is what we're all going to do now
until it's proven wrong and it just is
an example it's not a layoff example so
just just a final point that I think is
worth sort of focusing on and we talked
about it some before we go to if we go
to QA it is this notion that that being
in a time of crisis it's it's not just a
threat it's an opportunity and so that's
why I've got kind of the stupid hats
that that's one of my favorite slides
that there's all these thing
organizations that essentially we do
every day sort of mindlessly and we
don't think about them and and one
advantage of crises is it starts making
us think about what are we doing that
that gets in the way maybe you should be
great what are we doing sort of over and
over again maybe we should stop do it
and and one of the hallmarks that we're
seeing it's reinforcing and so if we can
move to the next slide slide 20 since I
don't think that I have power over this
one of the things that we are seeing in
a lot of organizations which is the good
news part of it is they're being so
flexible so imaginative and how you and
I we study organizational friction that
we can't believe what's happening just
to give you one little example and then
looking at huggy jump in and we can
start talking about some of the
questions but one
the things that's really striking is is
things are happening so much faster than
ever seem possible no just maybe one
example that there's a guy named Patrick
collision he's CEO of a company called
strikes where the peace company but he's
really into how do we do things faster
you know it'll say things like we built
the Golden Gate Bridge in a year and a
half how do we do something like that
again now would would take forever and
so he and some other rich folks
including Reed Hoffman the billionaire
Reed Hoffman just last week they put out
a call to academics for grants to do
research on kovat and just last week and
they promised people a 48-hour
turnaround and if you know anything
about grants and academia it takes years
it takes months to just get them through
the university administration it takes
six months to evaluate him and then it
takes another six months to get them
money in well that was last week this
week he could look it up they've they
had 4,000 people apply for grants
they've they've awarded 40 of them and
the money's been sent to the
universities how the heck is this
possible but I think the reason it's
possible is that during crisis sometimes
permission is given for us to do things
faster than different ways impossible so
so why don't want to be all flowers and
roses and everything's wonderful I would
encourage those of you who are in
leadership positions to look at things
with what are things that we've always
that have been so hard to do here that
we could now do faster so again if you
have any riff on that but but that
that's really an important point because
if we don't learn how to something from
this it would really be a shame yeah I
couldn't agree more with you above about
the opportunity for innovation if I can
be very quick and fast I think here the
most important emotional foundation for
innovation is not to sell a product to
somebody but to helps yes yeah when you
have the urge to help I think you make a
big difference
let me give you a simple example some
weeks ago I was actually attending a
conference with the
the company themself spectacles and you
know they were coming out with a variety
of how shall I put it frames and
different colors and so forth and what I
realized was you know when they were
showing all these spectacles and
multiple colors I was asking the CEO of
the company where is your help muscle
who needs these and he says professor
round will you mean by that
and I said here are your executives ask
them how many of them have elderly
parents a whole bunch of people actually
shot their hands up
I said what's frustrating to you with
your parents isn't it frustrating when
your parents go and visit a physician
they can't remember what the physician
said wouldn't it be nice to have a
version of Google glass where the
elderly parent goes there they can
record the conversation according to
HIPPA as soon as the meeting with the
doctor is over it's uploaded to their
children you've now helped people so
it's not selling a different color of
the spectacle but actually seeing that
as a source of health making life
convenient making life a lot more easy
that's kind of what I wanted to
emphasize well you know and I would also
add before we go to questions there's
research on this and I think a lot of it
can feel it in ourselves that it's such
a difficult time and and when we we try
to focus on well what can I do during
this difficult time to help others why
don't you feel sorry for myself
it not only actually leads to others
being held it actually helps our own
mental health is way up as well so
that's something they're both innovation
and mental health are aligned if you
will know you medicine let's actually
turn to the question questions Mona you
said there were a couple of hundred oh
my god you had a couple hundred
questions piled up and again you know I
my apologies if we're able to address
telephone but I will and our team will
kind of go through most of questions and
kind of pick out a few that are very
kind of some of what people are asking
and before we get started Bob and Huggy
do you want to let you know that we had
participants and audiences from over a
hundred and ten countries registered
[Music]
great I'm related to that you know the
first question that I feel like would be
relevant for a lot of you folks
especially if you work for a
multinational company or if you have you
know a team that is dispersed across the
world so in this case I'm this
particular audience member they asked
you know I'm normally Dean of a
cooperative between a US and the Chinese
University meeting while I was in China
was a bit of a challenge and now I'm
trying to lead virtually when I'm
physically not there makes this
situation even more challenging so you
know in situations like these do you
have any recommendations or suggestions
as to how leaders can lead effectively
not only across cultures but also in the
way where you know they can kind of
leverage technology or anything else you
know around them to lead effectively
when they're physically not there that's
a great question Bob do you want me to
take this question yeah why don't you
take this one sure so my point is a
great question
how can you be effective as a leader
when you're physically removed my short
answer to the questioner is you should
really think of establishing very simple
but powerful protocols to coordinate
work better so let me give you an
example so suppose you're the leader of
your team and your team members are in
five different countries or ten
different countries and so forth if
that's happening and it's a new team the
simple way to begin the first team
meeting is ask each one to actually take
a minute or two to share the worst team
experience they've ever been part of and
the moment they've shared with you the
biggest they've been part of
instantly you know I understand where
they're all emotionally this is salsa
salsa that's another hot button and then
you
actually be much more effective it's so
simple things like that can help a lot
so so building off of what huggy is
saying so a class that I taught last
term work it was it was supposed to be
in theory with our human resource
management executives at Stanford and
they work a lot on Zoom and other online
platforms and and and they came up with
some rituals to help to help sort of
deal with the lack of emotional
connection that you have in technologies
like these and little things like well
what's the best thing you ate in the
last week so you sort of talk about that
one thing that's happening a lot of
people scribed there for right now since
all of us are working online and and
nobody can see our feet so right now I'm
wearing the same blue socks that I
usually wear and other people wear
slippers and hardly anybody would seem
to wear shoes anymore so so those sort
of things that sort of create a bond and
an emotional connection can be useful
and and and then the other thing that I
would say and I've got colleagues
including my colleague Pamela Hines from
my department management science and
engineering she studies online behavior
in the thing that she really emphasizes
which is tough now but online
collaborations between people who even
get to spend one day together once are
enormous ly better so anything that you
can do so hopefully you know when the
köppen crisis eases to have some face to
face stuff woven into the online
experiences makes them an aura better
yeah quickly before we move on to the
next question the other thought that
crossed my mind is to the question the
reason when you are doing remote work
you have to emphasize coordination is
most people attribute poor team
performance to problems of cooperation
rather than coordination why aren't we
doing things well together well Bob is
dragging his feet obviously he is
dragging his feet and we can go do that
but the real problem is coordination
that's what you shouldn't lose sight on
next question please
great so the next question again we
might be relevant for a lot of folks
here is that you know what when you guys
discuss kind of the principles that you
introduced initially in our conversation
today are those applicable to middle
management and you know how would they
kind of change or adapt to leaders or
managers who are in that position where
they're not necessarily decision-makers
but also in charge of leading a team or
group yeah let's I'll start with that
some you know middle managers most
managers or middle managers there's only
a few at the top and you know the
classic line in the organizational
literature is middle managers especially
first-line supervisors are masters and
victims of double-talk and so so as a
lead as a middle manager it's if you
have even one person reporting to you
party your job is to do what you can to
to buffer them from the craziness of
above I describe this as serving as a
union shield at and sometimes what that
means is pushing back on senior
management just say to them well you're
predictable for my people and sometimes
you know and I hate to say this but if
you've got a lousy boss who doesn't
create any predictability or
understanding or control do what you can
in your secure your sphere of influence
to create a little plan to enable the
people who work for you to move for in
yourself to move forward with some
predictability so to me it's a
combination of shielding and any place
that you think that you have some
control including may become some what I
call constructive defiance because
there's a lot of times when our late
colleague Jim smart talks about this
some of the things that the great
leaders do is they ignore instructions
and do the right thing and sometimes
that's your responsibility and of course
if you can get yourself fired it might
be too extreme but taking some
initiative yourself sometimes is quite
helpful and by the way when things turn
out well if you've got a smart but
incompetent boss he or she might take
credit for you doing the right thing
Betty Rena said
the only other thing I would add is and
I think the most important thing for
middle managers is you have to do
something being inactive and waiting for
godot is not going to be helpful Groucho
Marx put it brilliantly as he said if
you do nothing there's a problem you
don't know when you're finished that's
great I thought I'd leave on an ID I'd
respond with that mischievous line
next question Mona perfect so another
question you know some folks have asses
to what extend you know as a good boss
or bad boss simply determined by their
temperament and and how can you deal
with someone who just has a bad
temperament you know someone feel like
someone who who might be crass you know
how do you how do you work with folks
like that I did write at least two books
on workplace and thank you 80
or 90 percent of the emails I got about
it which is about 10,000 emails that are
about bosses so so essentially
when you have a nasty boss you kind of
got three basic options I mean there's
there's thousands of options but in the
end you've got three choices one is you
can fight that and I'm a big believer in
fighting back if you can figure out how
to win that's right
so so that means you document you do
your political work but be very wary
about fighting back when you don't have
the power to fight back the second thing
is quit it's a little tougher what's a
lot tougher given the current situation
that we're in but if you leave and
anybody I've ever met who quit an
boss nobody has ever said gee I
should have waited longer I've never met
a single person who says that so is
quitting and the thing that
unfortunately a lot of us now with job
security being more difficult is
essentially finding ways and this is the
domain of cognitive behavioral 50 to
have it essentially do less
torture two years
all so this is everything from avoiding
as much contact with him or her as
possible one of my favorite ones been
that username one of my colleagues she
had an dissertation advisor who
would write her these long nasty emails
and what she would do is she would
answer them every two weeks so that was
the way she was like limiting exposure
to a toxic substance and other things
you can do it's more in the domain of
reframing it is view it as a joke you it
is temporary if you've ever been to a
kind of behavioral therapist you kind of
know what I'm talking about if you tell
yourself it's not your fault
because it probably isn't so to me those
are the three basic buttons get out
fight back
but be careful if you're going to fight
you know position you can win if not
find ways to make your song more
emotionally comforted and reduce sort of
like a toxic substance like kryptonite
reduce your exposure to it yeah those
are very practical pieces of advice the
one thing I briefly sorta had to that is
we all have many cells within us you
know one could be a nasty self the other
could be a much more positive self and
so on so even the boss was if you will
an that person too
he or she can have a better self in them
and so you're one of the things that you
that might actually help you is try and
get the boss cut in touch not with their
fears that evokes the worst temper end
but actually with the better part of
themselves yes
that's axon a geeky car that's like yeah
so the only thing I would sort of say is
the way I'd actually deal with the boss
like this is to something that's been
called the best self technique or
manipulation and the thing to do is to
go to the boss and say hey boss continue
why don't you tell us about the time
when you fact you were at your very best
you know where you were firing an ounce
you were accomplishing a lot talk to us
a little bit about that and I think the
more you get the boss to talk to us to
talk to this particular dimension of
themselves
chances are the more likely is that
going to be activated and I would also
add and so we're sort of in the domain
of simply the notion that people are
jerks or they're nice people we're much
more complicated than that right in
situations are very powerful and just
thinking about the situation that many
of our leaders are in if you want to
create grumpy nasty people it's we're
gonna when people are sleep-deprived and
you're in a hurry when they're under
time pressure this is all the stuff
that's happening at you and also working
online rather than in person is a really
reliable way to turn people into sort of
nasty people because they don't have as
much empathy for one another so having
some understanding of the situation that
we're all in right now is something that
might help all of us absolutely perfect
so you know a really important question
and I feel like there's also reflects a
what a lot of people are thinking is how
is leading a company or leading a team
different your industry is currently
doing really well versus you know if
you're working for a company or in an
industry that's currently getting hit
really hard by the the coronavirus or
the situation that we're in yeah that's
a really good question
BOM can I take a stab at it then you can
add in a man so the first thing is
listening to be begin by understanding
performance and if you look at
performance we can ask ourselves to what
extent this performance determined by
industry structure to what is to what
extent is performance determined by your
corporate parent and to what extent is
performance really determined by your
business capabilities and competences in
one of the more recent studies that has
been done they showed that performance
is largely shaped by business level
capabilities and competences
I think about 30 33 or 34 percent if you
look at industry structure it's actually
much less 12 or 13 percent if I recall
rightly and the effect of the corporate
parent is much smaller the rest of
course is all in as they say the error
term the equation I think the way to
sort of think about it is you know you
can have a two by two matrix tough
industry structure and poor performance
or a great industry structure and poor
performance or
tough industry structure and great
performance great industry structure and
bad performance so you have four
quadrants and the answers for all of
them aren't necessarily the same so even
in tough industries there are great
performers and we can of course learn a
lesson from then what kinds of lessons
innovation there would consist I would
assume of copying what they are doing if
you care many of the innovations we live
today a lot of them have their origins
someplace else you look at Toyota's end
on court system where somebody pulls a
record to stop the production line where
did that come from
from trains of course and buses that's
one modest kind of example so but the
point is what managers what's very empty
for managers to do is to blame industry
structure for poor performance and when
you do well you say it's because of your
business capabilities that's too
oversimplified an attribution all bad
things on due to industry structure all
good things on duty you it's a little
more complicated bomb you wanna
as a summary there is older studies that
show essentially when when things go
badly that leaders who essentially
almost take too much blame and say I
broke essentially I broke it I can fix
it
those are the ones who do better over
time and the ones who say it's not my
fault those are the ones who tend to
leave puppies that last well and someone
just has to has to do with this notion
that that when you say I'm accountable
the buck stops here people believe that
to this point if you if you broke it you
can fix it and then when things go well
you get credit for it so so having this
developing this confidence and
leadership is part of your job is
convincing people you actually do have
some control and maybe even more control
than you actually objectively do right
and I feel like it's getting to be one
I'd like to if you will offer a story in
the principal the principal first when
when you're doing badly the most
important thing that the leader has is
if the people working for the leader can
trust yes you know both Bob and I talked
about a very very famous fire called the
man garage fire that our friend and
mentor Karl Weick wrote about and what's
interesting about the thing is imagine
you're a group of firemen you're
fighting a fire you see the fire
encroaching in the case of the man Gulch
fire the leader was the one person who
said hey we can't outrun the fire
instead what we should do is we should
light a small fire around ourselves so
that there's no drawing material there
for the oncoming fire the can do to
actually ignite so let's set off a fire
let's hunker down under our protective
shields unfortunately even though the
leader said the right thing the other
team members did not trust him and what
did they do they started to outrun the
fire but fatally being fine
your tools are an extension of yourself
even though as they were trying to
outpace the fire they forgot to drop
their truth as a result they tragically
were consumed by the fire and the leader
who lit a fire around himself and hunker
down was the only one who survived so on
the one hand what crises like this do is
they underscore the importance of trust
but they also emphasize the need for you
to think about dropping your tools all
right I think that's a lovely summary I
think so I've been huggy
I was just wondering we wrap things up
is there anything else would you would
like to add I know we've had a wonderful
discussion and and had so many questions
coming in from more audience from from
all over the world I just would like to
end by just thanking everybody for well
for your attending for your great
questions and for your patience all of
us are sort of struggling with these
technologies these days so so I
appreciate all that and and stay in
touch huggy and I love hearing from
folks with outlet ideas suggestions
criticisms keep coming at us we we love
hearing your ideas and I'm sure I don't
know which 20 or 25 percent of what we
said was wrong but I'm sure that 25
percent was wrong so help us learn more
thank you great well thank you again you
know Bob and Huggy for joining us today
and you know working with us through all
of our technical difficulties and
challenges and again you know especially
for leading this very timely and
important discussion with our audience
so if you found today's presentation
helpful we really encourage you to share
the recording with your friends family
colleagues team members or whoever else
you know because again you know this was
a very important discussion and and it
felt like it was very necessary for a
lot of us to kind of peer in and learn
from how to I mean it's a crises that
we're in so again and thanks to all of
you for taking the time to join us today
and we also look for
to seeing you at our next event and make
and more information to come on that so
have a great rest of your day and we'll
see all of you see
you